- One of the reasons I wrote
the book is people are like,
"How are you so
optimistic about America?"
I'm like, "'Cause
you know that line,
history isn't repeated, rhymes."
- [Dave] Yeah.
- We've seen worse people
who had more control,
who were more intelligent,
and more evil,
and willing to go further,
they lost and they lost
relatively quickly and easily.
So given that it's not at
all ridiculous to absurd
to believe, excuse me,
that the same situation
in a different context
can be replicated
or at least mirrored
at some extent.
(slow music)
- All right, we're at the
local studio here in Miami,
and I am glad to be with my
good friend Michael Malice,
who has written a book,
very apropos, my friend,
"The White Pill,"
which I believe is
all about Betty White,
who played, of
course, Rose Nylund,
on "The Golden Girls" in Miami.
So Betty White, your feelings.
- It's actually more the
case for white nationalism.
(Dave laughing) Did you
ever see when she was on ...
- I was only able to
thumb through it so far.
It was half white nationalism
and half Betty White.
- It's a very odd combination,
but I get you there at the end.
You gotta start
back in St. Olaf.
- So I kid you not, I mean,
when I first saw the cover,
whenever you released it,
maybe six months ago as
the teaser, whatever,
I see this cover.
The book is absolutely
beautiful, by the way.
And I wanna talk about
the publishing part of it.
But I see this cover,
"The White Pill"
and there's this
sort of sitcomy,
the font you guys use reminds me
of like a '70s
sitcom kind of thing.
And I'm looking at
these women here,
and then Betty White,
I'm thinking this is a whole,
I honestly thought for a moment
this is a whole book
about "The Golden Girls."
- Well, it actually-
- So can we just talk
about "The Golden Girls"
which I know you're almost an
expert at the level that I am.
- I think I'm more of an expert.
- You might be more.
- Yeah, I think if we
had a "Golden Girls"
trivia competition, I think I
would wipe the floor with you.
- You have some of their
clothes, don't you?
You wear blanches negligees
at night or something?
- No, I have Margaret
Thatcher's dress.
(Dave laughs)
And I'm serious.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And I have two of her
bookcases in my house,
which as an immigrant is such
a sign of like, I've arrived.
(Dave laughs)
And let me tell you,
you do not wanna know
how much it costs to get
two 10 foot tall bookcases
from London to Austin.
It's a lot more expensive
than the actual
bookcases themselves.
- Yeah, well, I wanna
talk about Austin too,
because you have fled New York.
- Yes.
- You were a big
time New Yorker.
You were a Brooklyn guy.
You did not wanna
leave, but you did.
But hold on,
first with the book.
- Yes.
- Just some technical stuff.
So you self-published
this, right?
- [Michael] Yes.
- This is a self-published book,
but a hardcover
released on Amazon.
It's blowing up.
- Yes.
- You're taking out Mike Pence.
- Yeah, I'm ...
- Like January 6th style
according to you, no?
- No, I'm actually
doing it for real.
- Yeah (laughs),
oh, that was good.
- I am delighted that we
are at a point in time ...
When you and I were kids.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And people listen to
this when they were kids.
If you put out your own
book, you're a crackpot.
And in fact-
- Yeah, you're a
complete nutbag.
- You're a complete
nutbag, right?
And in fact, I have
a little hobby,
sometimes I'll get these
old self-published books
from like '60s and
'70s, and you read them,
and you think there's gonna
be some nuggets in there,
and it's really, really bad.
And I have one
book I just bought
called "Belial:
The Rebel Angel."
There's no references
to it online.
And it's the guy who
meets this angel in prison
and tells him about,
thanks to quantum physics,
all races are the same.
It's just, I'm making it
sound much more interesting
than it is.
But the fact that I can be
competitive with Mike Pence,
Obama, all these other
major household names,
when I'm nowhere
near their level
in terms of name recognition,
just speaks to how
much publishing
has changed in recent years.
And that in and of
itself is a white pill
because for over a century,
if you want to get-
- Which again, "White Pill.
- [Michael] whitepillbook.com.
- I see what you did there.
You said the title of
the book in a sentence.
- No, but I mean, I'm speaking
to what the white pill is,
as an expression of hope.
So for a century,
you had, if you want,
you couldn't have this
show 20 years ago.
- No.
- I mean maybe you
could have it on PBS,
maybe you could have it on Fox,
maybe let's say 30 years ago.
But in terms of publishing,
you've got a handful
of major publishers
which are shrinking.
They're trying to buy each
other out all the time.
And if you don't get a
book through one of those,
all these other outlets
pretend you don't exist.
Now, that is still the case.
The New York Times will
pretend I don't exist,
and "Politico"
pretend I don't exist.
Sure, but in terms of
me reaching an audience
and telling a message,
not only do I not have to
go through a gatekeeper,
I also don't have to
waste a year of my life.
Because as you know, if
you get a book deal today
on like January 1st, 2023,
it's probably gonna come
out January 1st, 2025
at the earliest.
Whereas with me,
I had it done on a Monday,
and I can have it out
within a week or two.
- That was one of the things
that I could not believe
when I did two books.
And I could not believe.
- Yes.
- I was like, wait a minute,
if I write these things
in a couple of months,
the first one I wrote
basically in three months,
I was like, I still
have to wait a year.
- Yeah.
- And then suddenly
when after that delay,
it's like, well, I've moved on
from some of those
ideas at this point.
- Of course.
- I try to write
something timeless,
but things do move forward,
and you're like,
man, this is archaic.
- Yeah, and publishers complain
that we're consolidating
and we're losing cloud,
and what are we
gonna do about this?
But there's not even a
hypothetical mechanism for them
to turn the ship around.
And that's a great thing.
Similarly in journalism,
wouldn't it be a wonderful
thing if The New York Times
wasn't The New York Times.
If The New York Times
was not in that position
to be the officiate and the
dictator of public opinion
for a large swath of population?
I think it certainly would be.
- Yeah, do you think it's fair
to say that it's not anymore?
I mean, I think something
does feel like it's changing.
It's been changing
for a long time,
but I almost think we're on
the other side where it's like,
if you were sitting next
to somebody at a bar
and they were reading
"The New York Times,"
if that's still a
thing that people do,
is that a thing that people do?
Probably not-
- At bars?
- Or at a coffee shop. If
you were at a coffee shop
and somebody was reading
The New York Times,
I would be looking at them like,
man, that is an ill-informed,
confused person.
I think that has now sort
of gained more momentum
than the person
reading The Times.
- Or you would think, oh,
this person is posturing.
They want you to see-
- Yes.
- that I'm sitting here
reading The New York Times.
- With their very
expensive coffee.
- Yes, so I think with a certain
segment of the population,
there were polls taken
the last few years,
and in terms of trust of
corporate media outlets,
just like The New York Times,
and with Independents
and Republicans,
the number has collapsed.
And once you lose trust, it's
really hard to regain it.
Someone's cheated
on their spouse,
you're never gonna look at
them the same way again.
'Cause you are, that person
has always been a cheater,
even if they have
learned their lesson.
Are you really
ever gonna be sure?
And when you have
these organizations
that just have constant
propaganda, so on and so forth.
But with the Democrats,
their actual trust in corporate
media has actually increased
over the last few years.
So what was.
- Is that right?
- Yes, so we're seeing
this bifurcation.
- Oh, good God, yeah.
- But if The New York
Times wants to be
the official house organ
as you would put it,
the left, that's fine.
People have much more
of an issue with CNN,
or at least CNN until the
recent heads were rolling,
than they had been with MSNBC.
- Yes.
- Maddow was a leftist.
Chris Hayes was a leftist.
They have their
leftist point of view.
Go nuts, speak your
Fox has their right
wing point of view.
Tucker, go nuts.
Sean Hannity, we know what
Sean Hannity is gonna say.
CNN like The New York Times
has this air of
objectivity and neutrality,
but when push comes to shove,
they will always fall
the inside of hard left.
And I think that disingenuous
is what the issue people have
with both The Times and
formerly CNN decreasingly so.
- So it's kind of
a beautiful thing
across industries right now,
because not only are you able
to get this out independently
and it's selling
incredibly well,
that you were telling me
right before you started,
I mean, basically
because it's hardcover,
they can't even catch up with
the printing yet, which is,
I tried to buy an extra
copy this morning.
It was literally two weeks
till you could even get it.
So it's doing really well.
We happen to be sitting in
a studio of a tech company
that I started that
you're huge on,
Locals, malice.locals.com.
We've started to actually
build the things.
I think there was this idea
for the last couple years
that republicans, conservatives,
anyone on the right,
whatever, hell we all
are at this point.
We were just gonna
complain about everything.
But it does seem
like it's turning.
- There were two
models for this, right?
So back in the late '70s, I
believe it was early '80s,
Roger Ailes was
trying to start Fox,
and they wanted him to be like,
"Okay, we want you to be
competitive with CNN."
He goes, "I wanna beat CNN."
But the other model was
for long time people,
I remember this in
the early 2000s,
people were like, we need to
have a conservative daily show.
And I don't think Locals
is the right wing
version of anything.
- No.
- It's not trying to
parallel something
that the left has
done unsuccessfully.
So I think the way to succeed,
and I don't think this
is necessarily the
right versus left,
is do you want to ape,
you wanna be like "How
I Met Your Father,"
or do you wanna do
something that's original
that you can't get elsewhere?
And by doing it in that way,
I think that creates
new audiences.
And when you have
freshness and innovation,
that's an apolitical thing.
And historically that has
been a function of leftism.
Leftism is very
highly correlated
with innovation, with artistry.
And it's only in recent years
that you have organizations
that can in some sense be
identified as conservative,
rightly in whatever
you want to call it,
that have been creating
things that are original,
or modeling culture.
- Is that the craziest
cultural shift
you think we've had that,
'cause the lefties were supposed
to be the creative ones.
That's generally
how it always was.
The openness, right?
- Right.
- The conscientiousness,
you're gonna create great music
and art and stuff like that.
Now they've become
the dogmatic ones,
and you have suddenly
conservatives creating things.
This is like a massive
psychological shift.
- I don't think
in modern history,
meaning let's say
post-Civil war,
has there ever been red states
that are the centers
of culture, right?
In our childhood-
- Right.
- it would be Boston.
- Yeah.
Which is now kind
of not a thing.
- Yep.
- Chicago was major
when we were kids.
Now it's not a thing at all
in terms of creating culture,
great food and so
on and so forth.
But it's not what Chicago was,
when Oprah and Phil
Donahue were there,
right.
- Yeah.
- And New York and LA.
Now, Austin and Miami
are both becoming
in their own way, cultural hubs.
- Yep.
- I can't think of any ...
Seattle was a cultural
hub in a small way.
Portland, Detroit,
none of these.
But now to have
a red state with,
Austin is a blue
city very much so.
Miami I think has a
Republican governor,
if I'm not mistaken.
- Republican mayor and governor.
- Excuse me, Republican
mayor, I meant.
This is historically an
America culture unprecedented.
And I don't know what it means,
but I am looking forward to
already being the big fish
in the small pond of Austin.
- Yeah, so let's talk about that
because I haven't had
you on for a while.
I still lived in that crazy LA.
And you still lived in
that crazy Brooklyn.
So we both made moves
since we last sat down
about a year and a half ago.
I take it you are
happier in Texas
than you were in New York.
- I didn't remember how,
I didn't realize how lonely
New York had gotten
towards the end.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- It was like "Survivor."
One by one of my friends.
I don't mean people
I've seen at a party,
just people I talk to on
regular basis moved away.
You're playing poker and
some went like, "I'm out."
- Yeah.
- I fold.
I have just a couple of
friends left in New York.
The majority of
them move to Austin.
And to be able to
have a social group
is something that is wonderful.
And New Yorkers are told a lie.
And I believed this
my entire life,
which is, "These people
who move out in New York,
oh, they're weak,
they can't hack it."
And at a certain
point it does become
like "Atlas Shrugged"
Ayn Rand's book.
It's like why am I
carrying this burden?
What is my upside here, so
I could stand up and say,
"Look how tough I
am a New Yorker."
No one's ever gonna
perceive me as tough.
- Well there was a time
where that had value, right?
- [Michael] Sure.
- There was a time
when the toughness
and the culture was there,
but it just simply
isn't there anymore.
- I went back over the summer,
I hadn't been there
for a whole year
'cause Tim Pool had
put up a billboard
of me in Times Square.
I'm like, "I gotta see
some person, right?"
This is bucket list stuff.
- Literally put you
up in Times Square,
your face Tim cast.
- Yeah, looking down at the
masses as is my destiny.
And I was so angered to
see that all the places,
because obviously
a lot of places
I adored didn't survive COVID.
You would think after a
year there'd be healing,
people would be returning,
you know what I mean?
I would say like a quarter
of the storefronts
were unoccupied.
There was not this
enthusiasm in the air.
There was really no place that
I wanted to go necessarily.
It is not fertile soil to
have a renaissance anymore.
And that is something
that even pre Giuliani,
I'd never experienced
in my lifetime.
New York's crime era,
people don't realize,
it was an opportunity
because if you
were a poor artist
who can handle living
in dangerous streets,
you could still get an apartment
and you could still go there
and create and make a scene.
And the rents are
too high for that.
And everything else
is too difficult.
You're not going to be a
cultural magnet as you were,
2030 or 30 years
ago, in the '70s
when the punk scene was there.
- So what do you think
happens to New York City?
Because to me it has
not hit rock bottom yet.
I mean-
- I agree with you.
- The times that I've been
there in the last two years,
it's more depressing each time.
There are no people
doing business.
That's what I always noticed.
Even in Midtown.
So I've gone for "Gutfeld"
so Fox is right in
the middle of Midtown.
It's supposed to
be people in suits.
That's what you used to see,
groups of guys in suits going
to lunch and doing business.
Now it's just people in
hoodies all walking alone.
Everyone looks like
they're up to no good.
And the whole place
smells like weed.
And I'm not against
weed as a general rule,
and I know you're certainly not
a against making it illegal.
- Right.
- But your business center
shouldn't smell
like weed all day.
- It's kind of scary
that having my face
in Times Square
isn't rock bottom.
I would've thought this
is as low as we get.
But apparently the
basement has a seller.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And the crime is
just something that
I remember as a kid,
kind of in the background
'cause I was much younger.
But to have that
kind of sense of ...
the thing that I think
is the worst part
is there doesn't
seem to be any will-
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Or plan to turn it around.
Now, if Mayor Adams was
like, let's try this,
let's try that,
or Governor Hochul was saying,
this is our plan to kind of ...
- I have a lot of faith
in her by the way.
- But they're not even
identifying issues.
They're just kind of being like,
"Oh, you're just making this
up for propaganda purpose.
New York is safer than ever."
It's just like, okay, if
people don't feel safe,
that in and of
itself is a problem.
So why are they misperceiving
in your opinion,
this lack of safety?
- So a guy like
you who strikes me,
you're such a New Yorker.
Like you are (speaking
simultaneously)
in the best sense of
that, I mean that.
So you go to Texas.
Now, you're in Austin,
which obviously is a
blue city in a red state.
Culture shock or did
you just get there
and you're good to go?
- Oh, well it's kind of cute
because some people come at me,
they're like, you moved to
the San Francisco of Texas.
I'm like, yeah, the
keyword here is of Texas.
This is not needles
on the street.
- [Dave] Right.
- Like complete Chesa Boudin,
District Attorney situation.
It's still very
Texan in its own way.
- But there is a pretty
decent homeless problem.
- No, we had a referendum.
They cleaned them up.
- Is that right? Okay, good.
- They took 'em ...
It's not like, no, it's
not like back in LA, no.
They used to be like LA.
- Yeah.
- Like the entire
street was tense.
I don't know where they went.
I don't really
care at this point,
but I mean, 'cause you heard,
it was really, really bad.
You could, I visited during
COVID, I was doing Rogan,
and I wanted to
go get ice cream,
and I had take an
Uber a few blocks
'cause the streets were
completely deserted
and the only people on the
streets were literal junkies.
I'm like, this is not
a good look for me.
This is not gonna
end well for me.
But now it's just absolutely,
I'm just very, very happy.
The fact that I can own
a gun in my own home
is just wonderfully reassuring.
'Cause in New York,
I have cool stuff.
I put it Instagram sometimes.
If someone breaks into my house,
I can't defend myself
or I'm going to jail.
They'll be much more likely
to prosecute someone who
defends their home with a gun
than someone who
breaks into the house.
Now, if someone
comes into my house,
even if they're my friend, I
can shoot 'em and it's Texas,
and I'll have no repercussions.
- If they are coming-
- So come on over,
Dave. (laughs)
- If they're coming for your
Blanche Devereaux Negligee,
they are gonna get a
bullet in their ass.
- It exactly covers
a perky bosom.
- What is it about Austin that
keeps it blue in a red state?
So a state that's
pretty functional,
that's making sense,
and everything else.
And then there's artists
there, obviously,
it's just a different thing.
What is the blue Texas?
- Well, I think-
- What is that?
- Yeah, I think conservatives
always talk about like,
"Oh these are the policies
in all these
Democrat run cities."
There are no
Republican run cities.
If you look at the top 20
cities of our population,
I think Miami's the only one
with the Republican mayor.
So cities are historically
run by Democrats.
And there's a lot of reasons.
One of the biggest reasons is
if you're living shoulder
to shoulder with people,
you have to have this liberal,
probably more
classical liberal sense
of live and let live.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Because you can't really
be in each other's business
if you're just
kind of this close.
You have to make these sacrifice
in terms of being a busy body.
And some blue cities
are obviously run
very differently than others.
There's a reason San
Francisco can afford
to have these massive rents
as Detroit, you're selling
houses for a dollar,
or Baltimore it is another one.
Or New York versus LA,
there's different
metrics that go into it.
It's not at all to me blue in
the sense that LA was blue.
People aren't wearing masks.
They're not having these
stupid virtue signaling signs
in the windows of the stores.
And I feel like Austin,
I think more than Miami,
and I bet you'd agree with me,
has become this
beacon for people
who are refugees within America.
Like a lot of-
- You think more than Miami?
- Yes.
- Why more than Miami?
'Cause I'm seeing the beacon
is freaking bright over here.
There may not be a perfect
way to quantify it,
but why do you say more?
- I feel like Austin has
more scenes than Miami does.
So we have like the
Bitcoin people, the ...
- We've got the Bitcoin people.
- Hold on, we've got
the Bitcoin people.
- I'm getting very defensive.
I just got here.
- We've got a bigger
standup comedy scene
I feel than in New York.
We've got a bigger podcast
scene I think than New York.
- Yeah.
- There's the-
- Oh, are we
talking about Miami?
- Of Miami, excuse me.
There's a biohacker community.
Whole food started.
So there's a whole lot
of white people stuff
thing happening in Austin.
- We have whole foods. (laughs)
- No, but you don't have
whole foods culture.
Do you know what I mean?
Like that stuff
white people like
where you're just
trying to go to the spa,
and you do the cold plunge
and then you do rock climbing,
all that stuff, absolutely,
I find anathema.
So I feel like that
kind of thing is more,
and I think Miami has
more history than Austin.
Miami's been a city
for a lot longer
as a major city than Austin has.
So Austin is in some ways
finding its own character now
as opposed to Miami's has
always been like a party town.
- Right.
- And we're not a party town.
- Right, I'm in the
burbs. It's very quiet.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- You're a dad.
- I'm a dad, there's lizards.
It's all very pleasant.
When it gets cold,
iguanas fall outta the sky
(speaking simultaneously)
They go unconscious
and you can ...
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's nuts.
- There was an iguana
in the airport.
- You think you got problems.
- It's not a ...
What's the problem?
The iguanas got a problem.
(Dave laughs)
- All right, so let's talk
about the book a little bit.
- Yeah.
- So "The White Pill."
Now, before we get into
the specifics of the book,
I just wanna talk about the
concept of the white pill.
Because over the last couple
months when I'm doing my show,
and it's like they
lie about everything.
Media lies about everything.
The politicians lie.
We do all the WEF stuff
over the last couple weeks.
- Oh yeah.
- It's like there's
lies everywhere.
The morons seem to be
getting more and moronic,
everything seems
to be so idiotic.
But I always try to end
my show with a white pill,
like that there is hope.
- Yeah.
- And usually I frame
that around what's
going on in Florida
and DeSantis from a
political perspective
that there is a place that
is a citadel of freedom
as he always says.
So first off, did you always,
is it built in you to
have the white pill?
The idea that there is something
better on the other side,
that we can get
through all this stuff?
And do you wanna define
the white pill, exactly?
- Sure, I'll define
it at the end.
This is one of my
favorite criticisms
when people tell me that,
oh, you have too optimistic
of a view of human nature.
Michael Malice thinks people
are genuinely kind and nice.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And doesn't see the dark
side ever, the North Korea guy.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- What the white pill
is, is simply shorthand.
It's an expression of hope.
And as I define it,
it's possible that we,
the people who fight
for goodness will lose.
It's not possible
that we must lose.
And you just in yourself
gave the white pill.
You can't look at
the WEF people,
and all these other
villains in our culture,
and be like, "I can't
stop these guys.
They're gonna run
the table on me."
These are often clowns.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- They're much more akin to
clowns than they are to gods.
But there's this belief
among some people,
especially among conservatives.
Conservatives take a lot ...
My famous expression is
conservativism's progress
is in driving the speed limit.
- Yeah.
- Conservatives have
taken from progressivism
this idea subconsciously,
they'll never say it
publicly or explicitly,
that being a victim is
a mark of status, right?
You talk about the
victim elliptics,
like, oh, where does a
black lesbian compared
to a Native American
paraplegic, right?
- Depends on the day.
- Depends, right.
But conservatives love
talking about how,
we're getting
attacked on Twitter.
I can't speak my mind
on Facebook, at my work,
so on and so forth.
And that's all well and good,
but part of that, often many
conservatives feel like,
well, there's nothing we can do.
America's done.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna be destroyed
in a couple years.
And my point is, you
call yourself a patriot.
Well, hold, you call
yourself a patriot.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- If you're a patriot
and you think Joe Biden,
or any person can destroy
America in two years,
take that flag off
of your profile pick.
Because if America's so weak,
that one administration,
especially the Biden
administration,
can destroy this
country irrevocably,
I'm not even saying the Biden
himself or the Biden people.
I think not only
you're not a patriot,
I don't think you're
an impressive person,
'cause that's just to me is
an absurdity. This is America.
Reagan is a major
figure in this book.
And he gave this speech,
I cite in the book in 1964
advocating for Goldwater, right?
And we're sitting here in Miami
with a huge Cuban population
and he was recounting
an anecdote of,
he had two friends and
one of them was talking
to his Cuban refugee
friend and goes,
"You're so lucky you
could escape here."
And the Cuban guy
goes to him, goes,
"I had somewhere to escape to."
- [Dave] Yeah.
- "If it goes down here,
there's nowhere for you to go.
This is the last
stand on earth."
And it was true then,
it's true now.
So glad. Part of the
reason I wrote this book,
which is about the Soviet Union,
I was born in the Soviet Union.
- [Dave] Yep.
- And I'm like,
okay, how bad was it?
And I couldn't be in
the position I am now
if I had remained
in the Soviet Union
or it later became Ukraine.
- So one of the things, we
just got the book this morning,
as I said, so I was only
able to read a little bit.
But one of the things you
talk about in the book
is that people don't really
realize how bad it is
until it's too late.
And often will actually
welcome in their oppressors.
And I feel like we
have a very specific
version of that right now.
- Yeah, one of the things
that surprised me to learn
while writing this book,
is after the Berlin Wall
fell and Germany reunified,
so the Stasi were the secret
police in East Germany,
and they were much more, they
were different than the KGB,
which is the Russian version
'cause they played mind games.
They had something
called Zersetzung,
which translates as
corrosion and disintegration.
And their goal was to
drive targets insane.
So they would do things like,
they'd break into your house,
and leave your socks
on your pillow.
- [Dave] Right.
- And then they'd do it tomorrow
and they'd do the day after.
And you have to sit there.
You'd be like, did
I forget to do this?
But then like, I didn't
forget to do this.
But then why is someone
breaking into my house
and putting my
socks on my pillow?
Why aren't they stealing
my watch or my wallet?
And you start to go crazy.
And this was by design.
After the Berlin Wall fell,
East Germany later became
re unified Germany.
They opened up the Stasi files.
So you could go and look at
what did they know about you?
And you could look
at who spied on you
and who informed on you.
And this was an enormous
question for everyone
who's a from East Germany,
do you wanna know who
was spying on you?
And do you wanna know
who turned you in?
And it's not like
someone down the street,
it was often
brother-in-law, sister,
your best friend since
college had been recruited.
Now we think, I thought at
least, while writing this book,
it would be like this,
Ruben's taken in,
gun to your head.
And they're like, "All
right, give us 10 names,"
and you give me up
and I don't blame you.
You're like, "All right, Malice.
It's Shapiro, it's Jordan
Peterson, it's Governor Sanders.
Yeah, we're all
conspiring together.
Just leave my kids alone,"
right?
- Right.
- What actually happened is
the Stasi recruiters said
a lot of these people
were just bored.
We didn't have to
put pressure on them.
They came to us because they
wanted to feel important.
They wanted to feel like they
were doing the right thing.
They wanted someone to just
actually listen to them.
We barely paid them anything.
And when you hear this,
speaking to me like having a
naive view of human nature,
people in America
need to appreciate,
and I think COVID opened
a lot of people's eyes.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- How eager the
average person is
to be an informant
on their neighbors.
It's not like you
think in the movies
where Tom Cruise has a gun to
his head and he is like, ah.
And he is like, 'Fine,
I'll name names."
No, it's like they
knock on your door,
and they're like, "Hey, I saw
Dave and Malice having a talk.
Maybe they're up to something.
You should go check them out."
And now he feels
like a big shot.
- Yeah that's a ...
Did you never think, I mean,
'cause you are obviously
fairly well-read
and have been around the world.
When COVID was happening
and we were hunting
down people at stores
for not wearing masks,
which I always thought
it was the funniest.
The crazy woman in the
mask hunting down the guy
for not wearing a mask.
You'd think you'd be
running the other way,
but they were always
running to tackle them.
Did you?
- It's like a zombie movie.
It's like I better go
fight those zombies.
No, go away from the zombies.
- Right, it was a reverse zombie
movie, something like that.
It was like zombie Bizarro land.
But that sort of thing.
I mean, when it was unfolding
and you were in Brooklyn,
which, so you're
on top of people
quite literally, right?
You literally have
people right above you
and right below you.
Did you think that it was
gonna unravel so quickly?
- I was very surprised.
I was very surprised.
I had this tweet, which I
got a lot of pushback for,
and I stand by very much
where I said, if you ...
'cause one of the big questions
that humanity always asked is
how did Hitler come to power,
and how did those atrocities
were allowed to happen?
'Cause we gotta make sure
whatever those steps were
aren't replicated
in any other country
or any other population.
And this was always like,
was there something uniquely
about the German people?
It something uniquely about him?
Was it the economic conditions?
Was it with the
Weimar situation?
And what I think
people just learned,
I tweeted out, I said,
"If you replaced the word
Jews with coronavirus,
suddenly the behavior of
the 1930s German population
becomes a lot clearer."
- Yeah.
- Oh, how can you say this?
- I remember this one, yeah.
- The point is, we saw no
matter where you stand on COVID,
where you stand on vaccination,
you saw how
effectively the media,
maybe even correctly
create an outgroup,
the vitriol with which
people were attacked.
The glee, I'm glad
they're getting fired.
These people should be
driven from polite society.
They shouldn't be allowed
to leave their homes,
they shouldn't be allowed
to get jobs, blah blah blah.
Even after it was
clear that vaccination
is not gonna prevent
you from getting COVID,
it's only gonna prevent the
severity of your illness.
- And by the way, that's
even unclear at this point.
- But I'm just trying
to steelmanning
as much as possible, right?
- Okay.
- So I'm trying to look
it from their perspective.
Even given all that, the hatred,
and the lack of
perception of those
who are in opposition as human.
And also the idea that like,
you want me to die,
so why should I care
about you at all?
When you saw that mass drop,
and you saw how
prevalent it was,
I think that was very
revelatory for a lot of people.
And it was surprising
to me as an American
because I thought America
would have a lot more pushback
than it had.
But that's just kind of
information you have to choose
and go forward with.
- So as a guy that obviously
is not for a lot of laws
to say the least.
- Correct, yes.
(Michael laughs)
- They come in with
mandates and shots,
and they're firing people,
and all of this stuff.
And then it all
turns out in essence,
at least from my opinion, to
be completely unwarranted.
I fortunately was against
all of it the entire time.
I am not vaxed, they
will never inject
this stuff in me,
blah, blah blah.
- Can I interrupt?
- Yeah.
- It's also different now
that you're a dad, right?
Because now your
kids are threatened.
It's a very different calculus.
- So what do you think
about this theory?
I've said this a couple
times on the show.
I think that one of the
reasons they went so deep
on vaxing the kids who
were at no risk, right?
They were never at any risk,
was not because of the kids,
it was because they figured,
somehow they figured that if
you can get a parent to ...
it's one thing to do
it to yourself, right?
And then have to deal
with the repercussions
if there's a vaccine
injury or something else.
But once you can get a parent
to do it to their child,
if you now find out the
child has enlarged heart
or a series of other problems
that are now arising,
your ability to deal
with that reality
that you had something to
do with it is so shattering
you can almost do anything
with that person at that point.
Do you think there's
something there?
- Absolutely, and
here's the other thing.
From their perspective,
I've never even heard a
counterargument to this really.
And people can feel
free to yell at me
all they want on social media.
The argument is 'cause
we know the vaccine
is limited efficacy, right?
So you're saying this
kid who can't get COVID
is going to get boosters every,
an injection every six
months in perpetuity?
Like that's what
you are positing.
And I don't understand
even a bad reason for that.
There still is, I'm not
COVID expert at all,
but I still have not
seen any argument for,
or against symptomless
transmission
that seems to kind of
be swept under the rug.
- Yep.
- And I think it's
very, very sinister
when you have kind of
going after people's kids.
And also the other thing is,
they have turned children
from the perception of parents
as vectors of disease.
So that's a mechanism to
separate the kid from the parent
in some psychological sense.
So I think all this
stuff is very sinister,
and I want to hear if
I can ask a question.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- I thought that all
of these mandates
and vaccine passports
were never going away.
And the fact that
they receded at all
in many of these cities is
something I was surprised about.
Were you?
- I'm not surprised that they
went away in the red states
as really as DeSantis-
- Well, no, but like
in New York City.
- Yeah.
- You don't have
to have a vaccine
to go to a restaurant anymore.
- So I'm not surprised
that once things started,
once the narrative
shifted a little bit,
that the red states really
did the right thing.
'Cause they didn't all
do the right thing.
People think the red states
all did the right
thing immediately.
It's not the case.
And even DeSantis, by
the way, did lock down
at the beginning,
but then people want
to get him on this.
But it's like then he
learned after two weeks,
it was like, no, no more.
So, okay, there's that.
On the blue cities, I did think
that it was gonna hold a
little bit longer than it did.
So that at least has been nice.
But it's left the cities,
the rest of the residue of it
I think has left the cities
with all sorts of problems.
And all the good
people left, right?
As you said, all your
friends, they left.
So they were most
likely somewhat
functional members of society.
- But it's an intriguing-
- And now they've brought
their skills to Austin
and families and
everything else.
- But it's an
intriguing question
and I don't have an answer
as to why I was wrong,
and why they did pull back.
And also at the same time,
it's still illegal for a
foreigner to visit America
unless they're vaccinated.
They just got extended-
- They just extended it.
- So there is a
incongruity here, and I-
- Well, do you think
it's possibly that it's
you can't do everything at once?
So this was the first salvo.
Let's see how far
we can push it.
We were able to basically
grade the pushback
and now we'll do it again.
Sort of like in Canada,
like you push back a certain
amount on the truckers,
you see how much
pushback there is.
And then of course
Trudeau's gonna
do something else in a year.
Like that you can't just ram
through everything in one shot.
- But the thing is they
had rammed it through.
So why didn't they normalize
vaccine passports
in restaurants?
'Cause that would be
a very effective tool.
And especially they
had the app, right?
So now you have an app to see
who's going to which restaurant
under what conditions.
I'm shocked that that
went away at all.
You think maybe it was
because they were shocked
in terms of the
population transfers.
Like the numbers are nuts.
The amount of people that
have left blue states.
- And it's also the whole
brain drain thing, right?
- Yeah.
- So this was a thing
in Europe and America
in the '70s and I think '60s
where you had these
onerous income tax
from European countries.
I know this is an
issue in Britain,
and all the doctors
and engineers,
and other established
professionals,
they started fleeing to America.
It's like, why am I
paying 90% of my income
when I have a high skilled job,
I provide for my family
when I could do that
much better in the states.
So that is something that
has a historical precedent
to it as well.
- So in that both of
us who pay attention
to the culture wars,
wary of state power,
all that stuff that,
we got some of this
stuff wrong too.
I mean, everybody did.
And I always say I grant
that the first couple weeks
I grant everybody the leash.
This was the first time and
this was out of a textbook.
So even if you know
everything about oppression,
we all got whacked out for
those first couple weeks.
Do you sense that it
will all come back?
Or do you think that the
pushback that you're describing
actually has now like
irreparably damaged the machine
or something like that?
I think we are reaching,
we're playing brinkmanship,
because whatever
you think of Biden,
whatever you think of DeSantis,
Biden has an enormous incentive
to crack down on Abbott
and DeSantis and other
rogue Republican governors.
Abbott and DeSantis and Kristi
Noem maybe to some extent,
some other Republican governors.
They are playing to the base
when it's like, all right,
I'm gonna give the
finger to Washington
and I don't know who's gonna ...
And we just saw with the
Kevin McCarthy thing,
where you had 20
Republicans who were like,
I'm not voting for the
establishment candidate,
come hell or high water.
They folded after some
concessions were made.
But that's still
within the same party.
So I don't,
and there is explicit talk
in democratic circles that,
the January 6th Republicans,
the Republicans are un-American
and wanna destroy the
Republican democracy itself.
I would to God
that that was true.
(Dave laughs)
So I don't ...
- You still got it Malice.
- Thank you so much.
I don't know where
this escalation goes,
but it's certainly a direction
that I am very
enthusiastic about.
- Right, so you're enthusiastic
because basically
if the state's just
all went their separate
way at this point.
If the federal
government was completely
broken at the knees,
you would be totally
fine with that, right?
- I would be giddy,
wouldn't you?
- Yeah, I basically
would be, at this point.
Well, I just see
no way around it.
I think the inherent problem
is that the blue states
will not stop encroaching
on the red states.
But if Florida and
Cali and Tennessee
and a couple other states
were just like, we're out.
I don't mean a civil war,
I mean just like we're
just, all of our resources,
we're just getting
everything out of the system,
the blue states will not stop.
They're not gonna want
anything from the blue states,
but the blue states
will keep coming.
- But this is something,
this is one of the major
themes of the book, right?
So, and we're dealing with
like the Soviet Union who,
I'm sorry to offend
the conservatives,
are much, much worse than
the Biden administration.
Let's have some perspective.
They did not wanna stop either,
but at a certain
point they did stop.
And they didn't stop because
they became nice people.
They didn't stop
because all of a sudden
they recognized the
value of human life
or they regard the
value of markets.
There were steps that took
place before they had to stop
and completely lose.
Now the whole point of this book
is like how did these
people build themselves up
and then how were they
defeated relatively peacefully?
And a lot of that
spoiled the book.
But to apply an American
context, is a function of will.
And a great example of this
is marijuana legalization.
Marijuana is still illegal
at the federal level.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- When you had different
states legalize it,
they legalized at the
state level and they said,
we're gonna open dispensaries.
And for a while,
even in California,
these dispensaries
were being legally
and understandably
raided by federal agents.
'Cause they're like, "I don't
care what Sacramento says,
this is illegal in
the federal level.
You are brazenly
breaking the law.
We can't have this."
- While Barack Obama
was president too,
it's not as if it was just under
a scary Republican president.
- And at a certain
point they're like,
it was like the cost of doing
this outweigh the benefits.
And even now drugs
are different.
I think Oregon just had like
almost complete drug
decriminalization.
It's still on the federal
level completely illegal,
and at a certain
point, it's like,
okay, the costs
of enforcing this,
and I don't mean just
the financial costs,
the political cost,
psychological costs,
whatever costs, cultural
costs are too high.
And they just basically
had to give up.
- So that gives you hope,
relating that to
something you said earlier
about how the WEF guys that
maybe they're more clownish,
I think that you
said than god-like.
It's like, so if we
just keep pushing,
that's what I was
thinking all week.
I was watching some
of the Al Gore,
you saw Al Gore ranting
and raving like a lunatic.
I was like, this is not a guy
who's confident in his ideas.
This is not a guy who's
got a lot, this is like,
I mean he struck me as
like Alex Jones adjacent,
I don't even mean not
to put down Alex Jones.
I mean like the level of
like screaming in theater.
I was like, something
doesn't seem right here.
- You don't have
to act like that
if you're running the table.
- Yeah.
- If you go to Vegas.
- Right.
- Right?
And the dealer who's gonna
win, the odds are in his favor.
You don't see the
blackjack dealer ...
- Yeah.
- The guy who turning
over the table
is the one playing blackjack.
The one who's in
the losing position.
So I think that we are
in a very hopeful time.
I think the number of
Americans who are aware of,
the gun controls is
another great example.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- 20 years ago you'd have
the gun control people
and then the gun rights
people, and they'd be arguing,
and at a certain point,
and I don't know what
the turning point was,
the gun rights people are like,
"We're not even
having this argument
'cause you're not
arguing in good faith.
You say you don't wanna take
our guns, we know you do.
We understand why,
it's a non-starter.
Every time there's a tragedy,
which is absolutely a tragedy,
which we would love
to be able to prevent,
you use that as an excuse
to take my weaponry,
and my ability to
protect my family-
- From the bad.
- from the bad guys."
- Yeah.
- It's like there's not
a conversation to be had.
So I think that kind of
understanding, I think,
and it comes from both sides,
I think from blue states
they just think
these MAGA people
are completely out
to lunch, mindless,
they're in a cult,
they love Trump.
There's nothing to
talk to 'em about.
That to me is healthy.
I don't think political
discourse can work
toward freedom.
I think political
discourse always works
when the two parties
come together.
You can have war,
and you have these massive
expansions in the state.
When have the two parties
come together to decrease,
to increase freedoms
and decrease the
power of government?
That's not a thing.
Maybe after World
War II when they
(speaking simultaneously).
- Yeah, maybe they've come
together every now and again
to bomb the hell
out of somebody.
But it makes us feel
good for a few days.
Right
- Usually.
- But not them.
(speaking simultaneously)
and those people grow up.
- Right, so, alright,
so let's bring it back
to the book for a second.
So the book basically is about
the fall of the Soviet Union-
- And the rise, yeah.
- Yeah, and then
afterwards the white pill
is afterwards and now.
But there's a lot of
weird stuff going on
in that part of the
world right now.
- Well, that's true.
So one of the points I make
is people have this ...
I'm an anarchist as you know,
and people both say
anarchism is utopian
and then condemn it
for not providing one.
Utopia's not possible,
but wins are, progress are,
I don't mean the
sense of progressive,
I mean moving in
the right direction.
And we see them all the
time and constantly,
and just one example is
the fact that they folded
on those vaccine passports.
I don't think that's a net win.
I mean it's a net loss, it
moved in the wrong direction.
But the point is, guns
is another example.
The fact that if you
look at Wikipedia,
it used to be almost
impossible to get
a shall-issue in
different states.
And now it's become
part of the constitution
in many different states.
The fact that you
have all these states
brazenly defying Washington.
Drug legalizations
is another one.
Whether you like it or not,
the fact that you have
states who are willing to
have markets that are in
defiance of federal law,
that is a step in
the right direction.
So, and I think the,
for a long time,
and this kind of hearkens
back to the Rush Limbaugh era,
there was this idea that's
Republicans versus Democrats.
And now I think if I talk
to most people and they say,
who do you think is more
of a pernicious influence
on American culture?
50 Democratic senators
or 50 executives of
The New York Times,
they're all gonna say
The New York Times
and they're gonna be right.
So the fact that
you're identifying
where this toxicity and
malevolence is coming from,
you're shooting at
the wrong people.
And I'm saying that
figuratively please.
- Yes, we will
make note of that.
- Yes, I don't wanna
be Sarah Palined, yeah.
- Literally, but
it is weird, right?
Because you'd think that
more people at this point,
well, you're saying basically
that enough people recognize it-
- And increasingly ...
- And yet these things never
change their tactics, right?
So I always say
it's like you guys,
The New York Times,
mainstream media, CNN,
it's like, you guys
don't have to be good.
You really don't.
But just don't be
pertinently horrible.
But they seem incapable
of even doing that.
- That's the thing, first
there there's an accusation
that conservatives
have echo chambers,
there's some truth to that.
But the amount of
echo chambers on
people who read
The New York Times
is just through the roof.
- [Dave] Right.
- There's no perception
that anyone who
is in the outgroup
can have any, even not
only just a good idea,
but just simply valid criticism.
- Look what they
did to Elon Musk.
They loved Elon Musk-
- Yeah, right.
He's saving the planet,
and now he's basically
Trump Jr. somehow.
So there is this kind of
increasing siloization
of American culture,
but that's really bad
because if I'm in power
and I wanna maintain my power,
and I see that there's this
big part of the population
that is a threat to my power,
even my power is
illegitimate and malevolent,
I still gotta know who's coming
at me, what are the metrics,
so on and so forth.
And they're just
talking in circles.
And I remember in
2016 after Trump won,
and this was a huge wake
up moment for many people.
The head of Times,
I think Dean Banquet
was just saying like,
"Okay, we gotta do better.
We missed the mark here."
And that kind of went out the
window very, very quickly.
- Completely went
out the window.
Gimme the white pill
on the tech situation
because, okay, so we are here,
and again, you're on
Locals, malice.locals.com,
I'm a professional, there
are things being built,
Rumble is building things,
there are, Bitcoin,
I know crypto's
hurting right now,
but there are decentralization
things, all those-
- Crypto's not hurting,
crypto's cheap.
- Right, so crypto is cheap.
So it's probably good.
But I meant hurting in the sort
of like broad sense of it's,
Bitcoin's not at 70 grand,
which it was a year ago.
But on the tech side,
it still does feel like we
got all this information
that the government literally
is colluding with big
tech to silence us.
Like quite literally,
there's evidence of it.
It's all out there.
I don't think these
NPCs blue people,
I don't think they care.
- They don't care,
they're mindless.
- I think they're, yeah.
- But I mean, I don't
think they're relevant.
See, this is an argument
I have a lot with people
who are for democracy
and I can't get seem
to get through them,
and it's just very frustrating.
When you go to a farm, right?
The farmer's always
gonna be out.
Who would you rather
have on your side,
the farmer or the 100 cows?
Then it's not a numbers game,
you're making it a numbers game
because you've been
taught since you're a kid
that the numbers
determine what happens.
But that's completely false.
And one obvious
example was Obamacare.
The Democrats had
super majorities
and so they had the numbers
in terms of politicians.
But the population
was like 70/30
against the 60/40 against it.
They put it through anyway.
So politicians used democracy
and the masses as a mechanism
to validate that which
they wanted to do anyway.
But if the populous
support isn't there,
they're still gonna push
ahead, they don't care.
All they care about is their
power and their agenda.
So yes, there's a big
percentage of population
who are functionally mindless.
And I don't think this is
exclusive to blue states
or blue people at all.
- Yeah.
- Blue voters at all.
But to me they're just
largely irrelevant.
I think what matters is,
are you going to attract
the quality minds?
Are you going to attract the
people who are innovators,
who are moving culture forward?
If Elon Musk voted
Democrat party line,
but he was doing what he,
Matt Taibbi is not
a right winger.
Glen Greenwald is
a hardcore lefty.
- Yeah.
- So Jimmy Dore is another one.
I dunno if there's beef with
you and him, but whatever.
- No, we settled it out.
- Okay, good, that's-
- Not even publicly,
we did privately.
I've never said
it on air before.
(speaking simultaneously)
- I don't agree
with them on a lot.
But I mean, when you have
people who are honest
and have a left wing
perspective, that's fine.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And who are a threat
to those in power.
There's so much talk
about how journalism
is speaking truth to power.
And one of the things,
this drives me crazy 'cause
conservatives always say,
"Oh, when I was a kid
journalists were honest."
No, when you were a
kid, you were a kid.
When you were a kid, you
think no one has sex,
no one does drugs, no one drinks
'cause you don't see
it, 'cause you're a kid.
So you're gonna be
oblivious to all these lies
and machinations
and misdirection.
But one of the things I
talk about in the book is
they've been at this
for over a century
and have the receipts
when the New York Times,
literally New York
Times was covering up
the starvation of the
Ukrainians in the Holodomor
There's a great book called
"Buried by the Times,"
which talks about how they
obscured Hitler's assaults
and the Jews because that
would be validating his view
that Jews are a separate race.
So I keep making
this point constantly
and I hope people understand it.
We all learn in high school
about yellow journalism, right?
And how they led us into
the Spanish American War
during William McKinley.
And there's a record scratch
and the journalists are honest.
And then like 20 years
ago they became dishonest.
It's the same people,
it's the same thing
for over a century.
- Yeah, I'm glad you said that
because I think people
think about it a lot
somehow that the
"NBC Nightly News"
and the "ABC Nightly News"
that it was all even
keeled and whatever,
but it was like, it
couldn't have been,
it just couldn't have
been by every estimation
of what we know about
how humans operate.
- And I'm sorry to all the
boomers listening to this,
but Walter Cronkite was a
lot closer to Brian Stelter
than he is to you.
And your life will
be a lot easier,
and things make a lot more
sense when you appreciate that.
- Even the JFK moment?
- Especially the JFK
moment. (chuckles)
- Especially the JFK moment.
But what about the
fact that they still
are colluding to silence us?
So I get it, they're
losing their ...
there's a certain set of people
that are always gonna be for it.
The machine may be losing
its power to do these things,
but it did things that are
direct assaults on our rights.
- 100%, right, yes.
There's not a dispute.
The question is, are
we in a better position
that now we can
have the receipts
and discuss it and look at it?
Or would, so Thomas Sowell,
who you've had the privilege,
and I'm very jealous that
you got to talk to him,
not gonna lie.
He often talks about how
people don't understand-
- He touched this hand.
Do you wanna touch his hand?
- Maybe.
- Later. (laughs)
- He often talks about how
people often don't appreciate
the concept of trade-offs.
'Cause sometimes it's
not gonna be like,
do I want a Rolls Royce or
do I want a garbage truck?
Sometimes it's, do I
want this garbage truck
or that garbage truck, right?
You have two bad choices.
So the choice isn't
between utopia and hell,
it's like, would you rather
have what we had 10 years ago
when they could have
done all this stuff,
and you'd never
know about anything,
and everyone would get
away with it scot-free?
Or would you rather have it now,
where not only do you
know who did what,
you have in writing
what they did,
and you could have a
conversation about it.
This isn't where I want
to be the second choice,
but in terms of is
this an improvement
in the right direction?
I think it's night
and day an improvement
in the right direction
over it was before.
And I think the trajectory
in this context is wonderful
because tech people, many of
whom are completely apolitical,
do understand that
corporate America,
meaning the corporate
press or government actors,
are often a virus
to navigate around,
and that they have their
own pernicious agenda.
- All right, so I want to
finish with a technical part
of the pilling of America.
- Yes.
- So people generally know,
let's describe each
pill for a second.
- Okay.
- Okay, so blue pill first.
- Let's talk about this
because this (speaking
simultaneously)
another one drives me crazy.
- Yeah.
- People are like, "Oh,
there's too many pills."
- Yeah, okay.
- If you can understand-
- I like the clown pill lately,
I've been big on the
clown pill, but ...
- If you can understand
a traffic light,
which has three, if
that's too much for you,
I'm sorry I can't help you.
For everyone else.
- Yes.
- It's two sets of pills.
- Red pill, okay.
- Red pill and blue pill.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- The red pill is the
belief that that which
is presented as factual
by the corporate press
is in reality a carefully
constructed narrative
designed to keep some very
unpleasant people in power.
That's the red pill.
- Thank you Morpheus.
- Okay, yes.
- That's Morpheus, right?
- Yes.
The blue pill is the
view that the experts
are generally good people
who sometimes make mistakes
but should be deferred
to and listened to.
And what we see in the
media is by and large,
factual and truthful
and can be relied upon,
even though sometimes
they make mistakes,
but they do their best to
correct those mistakes.
Right, okay.
The black pill is,
it's a wrap, it's done.
America, the west, and or
America is a lost cause.
Yeah, we're gonna have some
small victories along the way,
but given whatever trajectory
the person speaking wants,
we can't turn the ship around.
And there's no hope in
trying. The white pill is,
it's not possible to look
at the enemy class and say,
we can't win against
these people.
And when you put in those terms,
to me, it's almost ridiculous
not to be white pilled.
- Right, it's actually
very empowering, right?
- Yes, and, sorry,
just one more thing.
The reason I wrote,
one of the reason I wrote
the book is people are like,
"How are you so
optimistic about America?"
I'm like, "'Cause
you know that line,
history doesn't
repeated rhymes."
- [Dave] Yeah.
- We've seen worse people
who had more control,
who were more intelligent,
and more evil, and
willing to go further,
they lost, and they lost
relatively quickly and easily.
So given that, it's not at
all ridiculous to absurd
to believe, excuse me,
that the same situation
in a different context
can be replicated or at least
mirrored to some extent.
- So you basically
asked my last question.
So maybe I'll let you
make up your own question,
but I was gonna basically say,
so for my audience,
let's say that is
largely red pilled.
They don't believe the
elite class anymore.
They don't believe the nonsense.
They see what's approximate
to truth something like that.
You get red pilled for a while,
and then what seems to
happen to a lot of people is
you still think you're
losing along the way.
- Yes, that happens a lot.
- Right, so then that shifts
them to the black pill.
- Yeah.
- So I think you just
answered the question,
but what do you
find is the best,
is that really it just to show
them that this elite class,
they're not that good, this
isn't the best of the best?
So don't stay in that black
pill situation for too long
because-
- You know what else is?
- You can get to the
white pill, right?
- I think conservatives
are very bad
at celebrating a victory.
So one of the reason
I wrote this book is
I was on a conservative podcast,
and I'm like, why aren't you
guys talking every five minutes
about how Reagan and
Thatcher were instrumental
in ending the Cold War,
which was the central
foreign policy issue
for decades in this country.
And now no one even
talks about it.
It's why I had to
write this book.
I'm like, The New York Times
aren't gonna tell that story.
Why aren't you talking
about this all the time?
This was such a great,
a major accomplishment
that freed half the world
and made things so much
better for so many people.
And then my brain's like,
"Hey, asshole, you tell stories,
why don't you tell that story?"
So that's what I did.
- So basically you did a homer.
I'm a guy like me.
(Malice laughs)
Right?
That's what you did.
- That is-
- I'm a guy like
me, and that was it.
- Yeah.
- You got anything else?
Should I ask you about the
suit or corduroy in Miami?
I mean, what else?
Anything else you wanna do here?
- Well, I wanted to, it's
like a '70s book cover.
I did a '70s look for you, yeah.
- No, I got it. I just thought
if you had any other thoughts
that you wanted to share,
or I have to say your
hair is looking fairly
normal these days.
You've had some odd choices
over the years. (laughs)
- In all seriousness, whenever
I do a show like this,
I regard it as an
opportunity to have fun.
Because I think if you do not,
and this is something
Reagan did very well,
if you do not have
this sense of joy.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And Al Smith, who was
Democratic candidate in 28
was called the Happy Warrior.
I believe if you don't
have this sense of joy,
you're not gonna be able to
get people over to your side.
And for a long time,
progressivism had every actor,
every musician, so and so forth,
they're all the fun people.
And it's like, you
can't fight a regime
unless you fight
it with laughter
and happiness and smiles.
And this is Michael
Malice speaking.
And I wish more people
who were doing appearances
saw them as opportunities
to put some clothes on
that are fun and put
on a show for people.
You and I both know,
that for so many
people in the audience,
this is their only chance
to have the experience
of speaking with people
who have political views
that are similar to theirs.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Or at least have thought
provoking conversations.
They don't have that in their
school or maybe in their town.
So insofar as we can
make them feel seen
and make them feel as
part of a community,
malice.locals.com
is one of them.
I think that's
just a great thing.
And I think that before social
media, we didn't have that,
because you'd have that
one weird anarchist
in his high school, he
didn't know anybody else.
And now you can go and have
this community with others,
and not just on Locals, I just
mean on the internet itself.
- Yeah.
- And all of a sudden you
feel less like a weirdo
and more like an elite.
- It's a good time
for anarchist.
- It is.
- You can get on the computer
and talk to each other.
- Yeah.
- It's very exciting for you.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- And you could put out a book,
and put the former vice
president of the United States
in his place.
It's the number one book for
over a month now in communism.
So if people are learning
about communism through me,
I think that's only a good thing
as we sit here in Miami.
- Here's what we're gonna do.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna end this.
- Okay.
- I will go out with you
because you've got
some friends in town.
- Yes.
- And I want to show you that
Miami's better than Austin.
I wanna show you that
Florida's better than Texas.
- Okay.
- I wanna show you that
the Golden Girl House
is actually in Los Angeles.
- I know.
- And that was very
depressing for me.
- And it's not even a house.
It's like a front.
I know, it's a ...
Well, they have the house,
the exterior was
on the Disney lot,
which eventually burned down.
But the house, house itself.
- It burnt down?
- The Disney lot burned down
in like '95 or something.
- Oh wow, like "Shady
Pines." (laughs)
- Yeah, like "Shady Pines."
It was because of the s'mores.
You got it.
- Yes sir.
- You got it.
Good to see you, Malice
- Always a pleasure, Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all, right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.